[Musique]
je voulais te présenter mes condoléances
et kido marque
on était à l'école tous les deux et
aussi si jamais tu veux qu'on soit si tu
as besoin d'une épaule pour pleurer
nous miserons août en train de me
draguer l'or qui à peine deux secondes
en enterrer mon homme
voici ma carte et d'un je rêve
comment est-ce qu'un mec comme marc a pu
gagner 20 millions une femme cupide
comme toi pour soulager un gros coup
lyon en l'occurrence marc de la moitié
de sembler tu veux dire
l'épousé qu'on se prenne un pot tous les
deux ce soir je n'attends qu'un petit
bout de toi
[Musique]
non
la beauté il y en a plus pour longtemps
bientôt la rechange rannou cette fille
est une merde qu'est ce que tu gervais
une table ronde la place vous pouvez
faire de grands kebab supplément arrive
ça et suppléments et y
[Musique]
jusqu'où tu vas aller j'irais aussi loin
qu'il le faudra
m
je crois que la vengeance n'est pas la
solution tu n'en sera pas récompensé
[Musique]
vous marcquois lwin consenti vous
apprendre qu nicholson pour légitime
épouse
[Musique]